it's 1300 hours gmt i'm kamal santamaria
we are beginning this newshour with
breaking news on the russia ukraine
situation on a day that has been
dominated actually by suggestions of a
possible summit between the u.s and
russia we are now getting reports of a
significant escalation on that russia
ukraine border in fact russia's army
says it has killed what it is calling
saboteurs from ukraine so let's start
with dorset jabari uh in moscow
following these lines which are coming
out of the interfax news agency in
russia what more do you have dorsa
well according to the russian military
five people have been killed
as they allegedly attempted to cross the
border into russia now the
russian military also says that they
have destroyed two
armored personnel carriers from the
ukrainian military that were in rostov
region
on monday morning this means that
russians are accusing the ukrainian
military of having armored uh personnel
carriers on russian soil of course this
is something the ukrainian military has
just now denied saying that it is fake
news there i think this is significant
now because um the
news the information we're getting about
this incident uh allegedly is coming
from the russian military itself and not
the separatist leaders that we've been
hearing from in eastern ukraine in the
donbass region this is the first time
the russian army is directly saying what
has taken place according to them
of course all this is happening as there
is an influx of refugees leaving the
donbass region and crossing over into
russia as of friday when there was a
call for them to evacuate the women and
children and the elderly from that
region because of the ongoing
violence that was escalating between the
russian-backed separatists there and the
ukrainian military
the russians have closed the border
from their side so they're not allowing
people to go into ukraine they're only
dealing with the influx of people coming
in this of course makes the situation
much more dangerous not only for the
ongoing diplomatic talks but also for
those people that are trying to get to
uh into russia and into other regions of
this country the
rostov region is now one of the many
regions that is taking in these people
and they've also declared a state of
emergency we understand that over 70 000
people have left the donbass region and
are now in russia
and a number of them will also be
arriving in the capital moscow on
tuesday morning this of course is going
to be
seen as very much a
major escalation in the ongoing dispute
that is happening in that region and of
course this is going on as president
vladimir putin is due to hold an
emergency session with his security
council to discuss the ongoing situation
in the country's borders this is one of
the things the russians had warned
against and what the west was warning
against as well saying that there could
be a narrative russia built around a
so-called false flag operation to
justify any kind of action uh going
about going into ukraine of course this
is all unfolding as we speak so we'll
have to wait and see what more we hear
from uh russian officials in the coming
hours just hold on a second for me daw
so could we have the map back just
briefly uh showing rostov um let's have
a little look at that just to get uh
context so rostov bordering those uh
those uh russian separated the
separatist states of of uh luhansk uh
and donetsk the donbass region as it's
known and what russia is saying is that
ukrainian armed vehicles were destroyed
in rostov so russia is claiming those
tanks and five people who were killed
moved across into rostov
and uh they were killed as a result
dawson jabari is still with us in moscow
ukraine says
from what i'm reading here and you said
as well that it's all fake news this is
kind of the narrative isn't it that
there is this
concern about what is being said from
either side and who's telling the truth
of course it's very difficult to verify
the information on the ground in those
regions at the moment even journalists
who are in rostov region are not allowed
anywhere near the borders there is a
distance of a few kilometers they have
to keep away
so it's very difficult to verify what we
are getting from the state news agencies
here in moscow but they have said that
these disputed um border regions have
been uh part of a conflict that has been
going on for um over eight years now and
the dispute is really the between the
russian-backed separatists in donbass
and the ukrainian military of course
there was a minsk agreement that was
supposed to bring some kind of a
ceasefire to that area um but clearly
that is not what is happening now and
the russian president has said that this
is one of the main reasons there is so
much uh instability in that region
because the um agreement the minks
agreement is not being followed by the
ukrainian military of course the
ukrainian military for their part saying
is the separatists back the separatists
are the ones that are actually
continuing
shelling and firing at the ukrainian
army personnel in that region and in the
middle of all this we have to remember
of course there's nearly two million
people that live in that area there are
civilians that have really seen conflict
after conflict um in their daily lives
and many of them that we've spoken to
both from my colleagues in the ukrainian
side as well as the ones we've heard
from crossing into russia there's just a
sense of deep despair the men have been
told to stay behind
as of friday the women and children the
elderly told to evacuate
if you can imagine having to be told in
the middle of the night to leave your
father your husband your brother behind
leave your country and go into a
neighboring country not knowing when you
can actually go back home if you will
have a home to go back to so it's really
a astonishing um
situation and it's very very difficult
to imagine the human uh cost of all this
and the toll that it's taking on those
people okay thanks for now dawson jabari
in moscow
moving to
kiev now here's andrew simmons andrew
actually this is kind of what you almost
previewed when i last spoke to you in
our last news hour you were saying there
was a list of things almost which had
been claimed and and counter-claimed
and and now we can add this one to it
most certainly this really isn't coming
as a huge surprise uh to uh the
officials here and indeed ministers and
military commanders but it has to be
said it is serious there's no doubt
about that
the
immediate response is uh two words fake
news and the information war
has escalated
i would say much more than the actual
military situation you talking about 150
000 troops well you're also talking
about
millions of words not all of them true
about what is going on right now um
dorsa outlined the situation in the two
breakaway republics in the southeast of
this country where there is a
war all of its own going on uh and she
outlined the position uh in terms of the
alarm that was raised by donetsk and
luhansk uh in uh the past four or five
days the trauma and i'm not overstating
the case at all there that's going on
for the civilians
living in these uh these uh breakaway
republics and we're talking about
hundreds of thousands of people uh so
many of them who've been evacuated
now the rostov region not just rostov
city but the rostov region
is a very large
the
ukrainian military
say is absolutely no possibility
whatsoever that they would uh send in
vehicles or indeed troops or indeed
shell the area because there was a claim
only a matter of less than 12 hours ago
that
that ukraine had shelled rostov and
there was an inquiry going on in fact uh
uh we're seeing here details of of that
shelley of that alleged shelling um the
ukrainians saying
there's no way they'd have the range to
actually get a shell into the country
and uh nor would they have the
motivation why would they dimitro uh uh
the foreign minister who's in brussels
right now leading the forefront of a
call for an investigation into that so
really uh
not shock here at all expectation of
this and real serious concern
and a reminder andrew about what's or
who which country is actually really
involved here there's been so much talk
about a potential summit between
the u.s and russia and ukraine was
already putting its hand up to say
actually we're the ones at most risk
here
that's right i think you've got to look
back on at the weekend uh when uh
president vladimir zelinsky uh outlined
in his speech to the munich uh security
conference he said that uh the country
ukraine uh had to be
factored in more
with
talks negotiations because let's face it
its citizens are at most at risk with
this escalation in the conflict so
basically there is um a real desire here
to get more traction uh with the world
leaders in terms of particularly nato
and the united states with ukraine's
interests being put right on top of the
the stack so to speak and also
concern if there was to be a summit and
i say if because the kremlin has
outlined doubt about whether or not this
[ __ ] this uh summit could take place if
that is the case they don't want ukraine
doesn't want anything uh in the way of
concessions to bite into its own
situation here they want de-escalation
right away and they want a cease-fire
along this this line of the contact line
as it's called the front line which
separates ukraine from the two
self-declared republics thank you andrew
simmons in kiev
finally alan fisher
at the white house uh what have you been
hearing from the biden administration
this morning
well the united nations have now
received a letter from the un ambassador
from the u.s uh bathsheba crocker saying
that they have credible information that
if the russians were to invade ukraine
they have a so-called hit list of people
that they would immediately
imprison sent to labor camps or perhaps
even kill and on that list would include
journalists anti-corruption activists
people who are involved in religious or
ethnic communities and those of the
lgbtqi plus community as well so this
warning going to michelle bachelet
saying that there is real concern jake
sullivan who's the national security
adviser well unusually for a public
holiday here in the united states he's
been doing the rounds of the morning
shows in the united states just in the
last hour or so and he says what the
russians are planning is to repress any
opposition to them if their tanks cross
the border
we believe that any military operation
of the size scope and magnitude of what
we believe the russians are planning
will be extremely violent it will cost
the lives of ukrainians and russians
civilians and military personnel alike
but we also have intelligence to suggest
that there will be an even greater form
of brutality because this will not
simply be some conventional war between
two armies it will be a war waged by
russia on the ukrainian people to
repress them to crush them to harm them
and that is what we laid out in detail
for the un because we believe that the
world must mobilize
to counter this kind of russian
aggression should those tanks roll
across the border
as we anticipate they very well may do
in the coming hours or days
jake sullivan saying the tanks could
roll over the border in the coming hours
and days and that is a concern for the
biden administration they know there is
a meeting plan between secretary of
state anthony blinken and his russian
counterpart sergey lavrov on thursday
after the elysee palace in paris
yesterday put out a note saying that joe
biden and vladimir putin could possibly
meet the white house then put out its
own statement saying there's a lot of
conditions to this first of all no
meetings are going to take place if
those russian tanks cross the border and
of course they are deeply concerned that
lavrov and blinken might not meet if
they do they will set the agenda for the
two leaders how quickly that can be
organized where that will be held all
entirely unclear at the moment a bit of
the fog of war as far as the white house
is concerned but certainly the biden
administration in no doubt as we heard
on friday from joe biden himself
vladimir putin has made the decision to
invade it's not just a case of when
that's alan fisher at the white house
rounding out our coverage just for now
on russia ukraine tension